[Music]
we have already seen in a previous video
what average speed of an object in
motion is let's understand it one more
time as this is an important concept
first of all how will you define the
speed of an object moving along some
path the speed of an object is the
distance traveled by an object over the
time it takes to complete that distance
say the distance D is 20 kilometers and
the time it takes to cover this distance
is 4 hours what will be the speed of the
car then yes the speed will be 20 over 4
that's 5 kilometers per hour
look at the value carefully what does it
tell us does it mean that our object
traveled 5 kilometers in every hour or
in other words does the value of speed
say that the object traveled at a
constant speed well we know for a fact
that the car does not magically start
directly at a speed of 5 kilometers per
hour if speed gradually increases so if
the car was starting from this point
then its speed cannot be constant what
if this was not the starting point of
the car well we still cannot say whether
the speed was constant or not because
maybe the car was slow in the first half
of the journey and then sped up in the
second half the given data does not
imply in any way that the car will cover
5 kilometers in every hour so if this is
not a constant speed then what is the
speed called
this speed is called average speed
average speed is defined as the total
distance covered by an object over the
total time taken so in our example we're
given a total distance that the car
travels and the total time taken by it
to cover that distance and hence we
calculated the average speed of the car
for the entire journey I'm sure that
you're clear with the idea of
average speed now so what's next look at
the unit of speed used in the example
the unit of speed in this example is
km/h or kmph it's one of the most common
units of speed yes this unit is also
used in speedometers suppose the car is
traveling from point A to point B and
the speedometer shows these values at
these three instants notice at time t2
the speedometer reads 30 kilometers per
hour what does that mean is this an
average speed no it's not an average
speed the speedometer shows us the
instantaneous speed it is the speed at
that instant of time here
the speedometer reads 30 kilometers per
hour it means at that moment of time the
car is traveling at the speed it does
not say that the car has been traveling
at the speed or will travel at the speed
the value is only at that instant and
that is why we see that the pointer is
never really constant in the speedometer
it keeps fluctuating you are going to
learn more about instantaneous speed in
a higher grades in the next video we're
going to see some of the units of time
see you there
[Music]